Sheriff's struggle that you've experienced in life,
that involves your body.
Does every day count?
Um,
my name is April Mitchell.
All right.
Take off your room and look at your body in the mirror.
Describe the feelings and thoughts that you have.
Well,
I see a body that I've lived in for a whole 27 years.
Uh,
sometimes I've hated it,
but I've grown to be a pretty okay with it.
Now.
My name is [inaudible] Layla.
I'm 24 years old.
Oh.
I waver between loving my body and being extremely ashamed of it.
So oftentimes when I look in the mirror,
I don't know how I'm gonna feel after or how my day's going to go.
Um,
so it feels like a Russian roulette and sometimes it's scary.
so I guess sometimes I am afraid of my body.
My Name Is Giang Park.
I'm 25
years old.
It's just a lot of
robustness.
I see.
Um,
these tan lines I can fix,
but like
this stuff,
I can't,
my name is Chris.
I'm 31 and my eyes like assist,
not whenever I want it to be.
So it's a work in progress.
My name is Paige.
I am 24 years old.
I feel bold.
I feel strong.
I feel proud to be blessed with such a beautiful body,
beautiful skin,
and so much,
so much light.
All right.
So what makes your skin unique?
I guess I like that I can tan easily.
Um,
I don't know.
Would you like to go first?
How did it go from there?
Um,
so my skin,
um,
I have something called middle I go.
So it's a condition where you lose patches of the pigment,
of your skin.
Um,
my skin is unique because I'm the only one that has these exact colors and these
exact places with these exact pictures.
Like I can find little hearts and little things up in my slides.
Yeah.
I used to have one of my finger and then it kind of shifted.
I had a snowman on my back and my mom like painted a little top hat,
like a little carrot nose.
I think I'm pretty happy in my skin.
Um,
I've grown to love the little things that make me me and made me different.
It doesn't look like,
you know,
every supermodel in every magazine,
every actors on TV.
It's a little more artistic than,
than some with the different coloring.
But yeah,
I think that my body's beautiful.
Sure.
A struggle that you've experienced in life that involves your body.
Who
uh,
does every day cow?
Um,
I would say I struggled a lot dealing with my skin color because it was really
hard for me to fit in.
Like I was,
I was,
um,
considered dark,
but I'm not African,
so all the Africans look at me like,
oh,
you're not African.
I'm like,
no.
Then all the black people look at me like,
Oh,
you,
you have to be African.
I'm like,
no.
It's kind of hard dealing with people's perception of me prior to meeting near
the assumptions they make about me and I've had to experience that
educationally,
professionally,
everywhere I go.
So now it's kind of like a badge of honor,
kind of bashing stereotypes.
Right.
You where I go.
What about yourself?
What,
um,
a lot of stuff like going up like health wise,
I like puberty and stuff or like I had like pretty bad acne from like middle
school until like,
like middle of college and then I got some medicine for it and it cleared up
really quickly.
The insecurity was always there.
Still it doesn't go away very quickly.
Um,
so I think I carried myself kind of the same but like it wasn't until like a
little bit later when like I gained more confidence in myself after the fact.
I like that.
Nice.
You know,
I tried to like get the ideal body that's like by the media standards.
So that's,
that's just not where I want it to be.
When you're bombarded by like so many like different like pictures of like,
you know,
nice bodies and stuff that's like kind of like what you strive towards.
You got to put the work in,
but you know,
that's
Hawaii I guess idealize it.
I was broke the hall
sad.
Okay.
Do you struggle with any aspects of your skin?
So I grew up with really like bumpy skin and I don't really know what it is.
But um,
as a child I've been called like chicken skin and all that because people will
go like,
what's that on your arm?
Like your legs?
And I'm like,
I don't know.
I was just born with it,
you know,
kind of bugs me a little bit,
but not so much anymore.
I kind of have like a little,
yeah,
bit of bumps on my skin too,
just like on my forearms.
And then,
um,
I struggle really hard with,
I take chemo every day and like that causes a rash.
And so struggling with having to take something cause I need to live and then on
top of it it causes me to look very different.
Um,
and have people make fun of me cause they don't know like what I'm battling
against.
Um,
and then also just like,
it affects how we perceive ourselves too.
You know,
like when it looks,
when you feel like you look different than what's normal or the standard.
A lot of people when they first look at me,
they would never assume that right now I'm battling cancer and um,
and not just like any type,
it's just like a really advanced stage.
Learning to like love my body through living with something that wants to kill
me inside of it is,
it is a huge dichotomy.
How can I love me?
I love my body when I'm housing something that is so hell bent on killing me so
hard.
It's hard.
What is your favorite activity to do that involves your body?
Okay.
I like to get tattoos on my body.
I think it's a way to express myself artistically and it's there permanently.
So I just feel like it's another way to celebrate my body,
my art,
my creativity through tattoos.
So I love that process.
I get to go through that pain,
the joy,
the whole process.
I love that.
I feel that I started getting tatted as a way after I was dealing with self
injury for awhile.
Um,
I have a lot of scarf vacation,
so I kind of got it as a way to cover it up,
but now it's just become kind of a means of me,
um,
to really express myself.
Kind of like what you were saying,
like you can kind of completely get to know me just based off of looking at my
tats and asking me questions.
Um,
and so I got my chest Tattoo,
um,
after I got diagnosed with cancer and I kind of went against my doctor's orders
and got it anyways,
um,
because I have blood cancer,
so that's really,
you should not be doing that.
But um,
it pretty much is representative of things that have been important in my tribe.
And so I have a snake and arrowhead and it's in the shape of it.
The Congo Cosmogram,
which is African cosmology.
That's beautiful.
One of my favorite tattoos is for my grandmother.
It's a clock and it has orchids with her initials and it has one of my favorite
quotes.
In the end,
everything will be okay if it's not okay,
it's not the end.
And it's kind of like a reminder to me,
like everything might seem like it's crumbling around me,
but I know at the end of the day I will be settled.
I will be okay as long as I understand it's not the end.
Like my storm is not the end of what I'm going through now.
My skin has taught me so much about myself and so much about what I can handle.
It's taught me how to be confident and how to walk into a room and command
attention.
I'm realizing and I'm learning every day that self love is the best love.
So I'm learning to accept me for what I have.
When I wake up in the morning,
I always tell myself,
you're beautiful,
you're kind,
you're all these things.
So there's absolutely nothing I would change about my body because I know that I
was made perfectly imperfect.
Oh,
are you afraid of aging?
Why not really?
I try to be present and conscious and stay here.
Yeah.
So like why waste energy anyway?
Why waste energy?
It's going to happen to everybody.
I mean,
whatever happens when you get older happens.
I have a similar mindset where it's like,
yeah,
it's just,
things will just happen.
Everyone has their own timeline.
Do you want to get like really old or like,
do I want to get really old?
I feel like,
I don't know.
With our technology now,
you know,
anything can happen.
I think people are like
thinking about living forever.
Right?
Oh,
okay.
That's all.
It was too far.
Know that there's been a lot of like,
you know,
like love your body campaigns and stuff like that,
which kind of helps a little bit.
I tried to love my body.
I know that it's the only one I have.
So I look at myself and I just,
I just gotta look at myself and I go like,
this is it.
You know?
I think the only thing I like about my body is these little happy trails right
here.
I don't know why I think it's cute.
Okay.
I'll ask you the question.
Describe a physical trait of the person across from you that you admire.
Ooh.
Called traits.
I think just your smile.
If that counts.
You seem so confident and happy and you can just exude that confidence,
which I,
I love PBS of.
Yes.
Thank you.
A physical trait.
I would say that you have that I admire one a top.
You're gorgeous.
Let's get that out the way.
But I would say the grace you have,
and I'm only catching a glimpse of you,
but I,
I would say the grace you have and the confidence you have in expressing your
vitiligo and sharing this information,
I think that's beautiful.
So I would probably say your grace.
You're very,
you're very regal and elegant.
Yeah.
I love that.
Of course.
So Nice.
I think it's only natural as human beings to want to change things about
ourselves.
I think that when I was younger,
there were definitely things that I would much rather change about myself than
there are now.
I think my body reflects me in the sense that
it has a will to live.
It's resilient,
just like my spirit.